breaking overnight from Puerto Rico
there are reports governor Ricardo Rose
AO is set to resign as early as today
it follows days of protests after the
leak of controversial chat involving the
governor and members of his staff CTM
lead national correspondent David Pegg
know is in San Juan so David what are
you learning we have not confirmed the
reporting that is happening here on the
island from two of the largest
newspapers that the governor is going to
resign this is the gate that a vehicle
would come out of if in fact the
governor is at the residence we've gone
from the residence to two different
airports amid a flurry of reports that
the governor may have already exited the
island on a private plane here are the
two front covers that essentially are
saying the governor is set to exit today
this all comes on the heels of the
governor's interim chief of staff saying
I'm out that happened yesterday and it
actually happened his protesters were in
front of the Capitol if you followed our
reporting this week for the last 11 days
straight protesters have gathered
Millennials leading the effort to oust
the governor who has faced allegations
of corruption how did this all start it
started after a profane laced chat that
came from leaked text messages that
involved the governor and eleven members
of his staff we are walking right now to
the other side of the Capitol where
police are staged this morning
information is very tight there is not a
representative of the governor who will
answer the phone right now but the
largest outlet on the island el nuevo D
is reporting that before noon today we
may see a video of the governor
announcing his resignation Tony when
that news breaks we know you will have
it David beg no force continuing our
coverage in Puerto Rico thank you very
much